welcome back to another episode of the
recruitment mentors podcast I'm your
host Hisham azuz and on this week's
episode I was joined by Guy Walker who
is the CEO and founder of a business
called talentia group he started this in
2018 and now they have nine recruitment
Brands within the group and an umbrella
company within this group they operate
in markets such as engineering education
Healthcare sales marketing and they have
around 90 people across the group I
absolutely love guy's passion enthusiasm
for what he's building with his business
but also for his career and what they're
trying to do at talentier group we spoke
about so many things from leadership
from spinning loads of different plates
from how a guy has continued to have to
evolve as a leader and how he's got way
better at building a blueprint and
backing people to go into different
markets and so so much more enjoy the
episode guy welcome to the podcast
thanks for having me on I'm really
excited I've been looking forward to it
for a few weeks yeah thanks for making
the trip where have you come in from
because I know you're you just find
yourself in different parts of the the
UK uh is Manchester into Bristol into
London uh which was an exciting drive as
you can imagine the m6 is a car park
so I'm I'm really excited to sort of
unpack this journey that you're on or
the journey that you've been on so far
and I guess I always sort of uh think
it's useful for people listening just to
understand like where you are today
some Key Parts if there's anything that
I've missed fill it in but just to give
people context
um you have your own recruitment
business a group of companies which is
called talentier group yeah talent to
your group yeah um there's nine
recruitment Brands within that um and an
umbrella company which all started in
May 2018. so the different brands within
that in terms of the sectors they
operate in we've got engineering
sustainability and Tech Finance
education Healthcare sales marketing and
you also have a US operations and team
as well yep and I think you also
mentioned around the talentier
Management Services as well within that
you've got circuit 90 people across the
group sixty percent
um uh lent to contract Business 40 perm
and uh you start this business on your
own yeah but then quite early on brought
on um a really good friend of yours that
I'm assuming came in that sort of
director level yeah he's the other
director so it's me and Elliot Redmond
okay
so a lot to unpack my friend loads
but I guess we're always like to start
is is a million pound question and uh I
think it's it's something that a lot of
people think about particularly when
they start their own recruitment
business Journey so I'd love to hear
your take on the characteristics and
traits that you believe make up a highly
successful recruitment consultant in
today's market I've got to stay true to
form there's a there's a talentia Brand
answer that will really encapsulate what
we look for and then that's what I am
and what my team are so we look for for
three things and and they'll probably be
mimics across the industry but I look
for hard work and examples of hard work
and delivering on hard work that doesn't
have to be 90 hour weeks it doesn't have
to be like really pushing yourself or
like not sleeping for a week that you
can just be someone that's willing to
put in a shift when you need to there's
a big glorification of overworking and
working for 15 hours a day and really
burning yourself out and what you
actually need to do is work hard when
you need to and rest when you don't need
to so we look through examples of people
that I've put in a shift come up against
challenges and overcome those which
bleeds really nicely into the second
thing that's really really important and
that's resilience in recruitment you get
hit up and down up and down everyone
will be familiar with the recruitment
roller coaster we sit on it every day
strapped in ready to go and I'll be
really honest if you're not resilient
it's not the right industry there are
there are ways to make it easier but
being able to take a take a metaphorical
slap take the emotional ups and downs
and being able to push on through that
to get the result you're looking for is
probably the second most important trait
and that the third and final thing which
I think I've got bags of and and that
comes across
in May is Passion you really have to
give
if you have to give yourself you have to
care there's another phrase there of
course but you really have to want it
and really want the best for yourself
recruitment is a roller coaster and a
ride but if you get on at the right time
and you ride that Journey you'll get
everything you've ever wanted from a
career from recruitment it offers a full
spectrum career it really does mean that
people can have everything they want
from life and if you're passionate and
you care that will come through in the
work that you do and you pass that on to
your clients and your candidates and
your colleagues so top three
hard-working resilience and passion I
love that so I really want to sort of
hone in and focus on your
entrepreneurial Journey but I guess just
to
um touch on it obviously how long did
you work for another business or other
businesses before you started talentia
in 2018 yeah I was a recruiter for a
large education business for close to
five years
I left that business after being quite a
high performer um I kind of hit every
trip my one of my accolades I've gone to
Vegas five times fifth time was pretty
boring I'll be honest there's only so
many nightclubs you can go to and only
so much money you can lose on the table
before you're like right what's this so
I've been with them for a long time
um unfortunately I lost my mum
um in 2017 to a really aggressive form
of cancer and the idea of going back
into the same rigmarole the same work in
the same way really really put me off
and I couldn't focus so I had to go and
do something and the only thing I've
ever known really in the most recent
years has been recruitment so I went
home to recruitment but not home to the
business and that was a massive
challenge a really difficult time but it
was the only thing I felt was right to
do and we've just cracked on from there
and it's been a a hell of a journey so
that is so interesting to say like so I
like this is a pretty raw and recent but
like literally yesterday I went to my
first ever funeral I'm 29 years old so I
count myself quite lucky and my my
girlfriend's sorry cousin um it was it
was it wasn't close to me but obviously
my my partner it's my girlfriend's
cousin she lost her life to really
aggressive cancer as well she's like
super young super prom fair but like the
only the thing just thinking about
yesterday and stuff I don't know if
these are some of the things that you
felt was just just perspective like like
you said they're like go back to the
same job do the same thing I don't know
I think instantly you can be brought to
like wow okay yeah life does end is is
this all worth it do you know what I
mean so did you just spring straight not
straight to that but you were like wow
okay
um do I want to count on doing this or I
don't know
why do you work for people right
if I work you work for you you work for
what you enjoy and what you love and I
found that I love to different things I
used to love the lifestyle I used to be
a recruiter that was out five nights a
week I used to love the trips the
incentives all that stuff that really
when you're new in recruitment is fun I
suddenly realized I was old right and I
wasn't old I was 25 but I felt wise
beyond my years I felt emotionally burnt
beyond my ears and I needed to figure
out why I worked for someone I couldn't
I couldn't work for those people no I'm
not gonna bow back from nothing like
that I couldn't work for them I didn't
buy into their vision for what they were
trying to achieve
and I knew that I could do better and I
could do better for myself I wasn't
going to let myself down anymore working
in that same role in that same place in
that same job and I knew that I could
create something that was truly special
and that's how I set about building what
I built now and and it's still true to
itself from the the time before it still
still rides on on Family First and that
was what I put at the Forefront of
everything my mum was incredibly special
she was a very special woman I wouldn't
bore anyone with that but she was very
very special and she put family at the
front of everything and so I then put
family at the front of everything I did
so now in my business Family First is
the phrase you hear 10 times a day put
your family first it doesn't matter
whatever it is family first and so that
because I've heard you say then you you
started this business with 15 grand yup
after your mom passing and that's what
we started wow it came from her yeah she
absolutely yeah she she she left me a
bit of money in a pot to go out had a
bit of money friend lent me a bit of
money and um we went from there really
um it was quite expensive at the
beginning for sure but that money went
far
we made it stretch for sure what what
was like because obviously when I sort
of shared with everyone what the
business looks like today
like when you started the business in
2018 like did did Guy have this Grand
Vision of it's going to be a number of
different recruitment Brands like what
what was the initial mindset was it like
right let's give this a real go let's
yeah get as much money in the bank as we
can let's try and make this success like
what was the initial I was it wasn't
about money and that's weird for a
recruiter to say that was this like 100
Grand figure I wanted 100 Grand a year
that was like that was cool that was
that was enough to live I didn't need
any more than that 100 Grand to some
people was a shadow of money 100 Grand
to others is not I wanted to build a
company that comfortably paid me a
hundred grand and I could love it I
actually just set about doing things
better like I felt that the recruitment
industry needs to hold itself to a
better account we as an industry need to
invest better into people so we kind of
just cracked on investing in people like
me and my best mate he's a trainer and
I'm a I'm a bill I'm a doer I get on the
phone I win business I win clients I'll
smash it out apart that's my job that's
what I get paid to do my best mate was
the person that invested in the in
people and he would have the patience
and the time to sit and show them how to
be better and our top hires like my my
top seven people had no experience so my
my top team now that are all incredibly
talented like some of the best you've
you've seen in recruitment in my opinion
of course I'm biased but they have
nothing they they just had the right
mindset and through our investment and
through being a team we scaled the thing
straight away but it started on just
doing things better than people had done
them before actually caring about your
client and caring about your candidate
was so integral we yeah we went for a
bit of an undercut strategy we were
transparenting our margins which gave
honesty Integrity to the market we were
really clear about where we wanted to go
and what we wanted to do with our
customers and then we've evolved since
then and we've evolved in a way that
meant we could pay back to our customers
and invest in our USPS and our product
recruitment as a service and you really
have to understand what service you're
offering so many recruiters kind of come
in and just do recruitment we offer
within recruitment a better service
whether that's a way to improve the
teachers that we place or a way to make
sure that the construction workers we
put out there are safer or a way to make
sure our Engineers use more sustainable
practices all of our brands have really
integral USPS that add value to the
candidate and in turn to the client and
they're embodied by the Consultants that
represent them so what what did this
business look like the end of year one
then so you obviously brought on one of
your good friends like was you just
doing one market how many different
markets are you in we started doing
business look like we started in
education education was our biggest
brand that's where I came from
um we quickly merged into we quickly
created an umbrella company because we
could see the umbrella companies were
making a load of money out what they
were doing and we thought actually why
are we sending this money off to another
brand when we can do the same job
control it in-house and give better
customer service brought it straight
in-house created a brand and moved that
along that's now a self-sufficient
business
um I think it was 10 of us end of year
one and just education just education
and we've made 15 grand which
it was tough
you made 15 grand yeah first year which
was tough I think if you expect to make
a massive return but we had so many
staff who expanded so quickly you kind
of you take what you can right that paid
everyone and everyone was happy I was on
salary at that point so I was like
they're cool everyone's paid up and
there's 15K left over and year two was a
scary scary time
ah the pandemic yeah schools and
colleges never closed education is
gold-plated right that we will always be
busy there's always a demand for what we
do covers flipped that on his head I had
some scary nights I think loads of
people remember having a whiteboard and
going case one case two case three oh my
God case four case five is like uh
selling your house and just giving up on
everything altogether and me and my my
best mate my director had to sit through
those decisions and those choices
in that pandemic so we lost 150 000
pound Year too but we lost no staff we
kept everyone that we could on the
furlough scheme that was eligible and we
kept them through we had a few people
that weren't eligible for when they
started we paid them for as long as we
could but quickly we realized market
conditions were turning against us
um in a really dramatic way so every
month I was trading I was losing roughly
20 grand but how does that feel
I've got a really good sticking point I
was sat near the Seven Bridge in Bristol
overlooking the Seven Bridge and I was
like cool this bridge is big and I'm
small and I rang my dad and it was
absolutely raining absolutely putting it
down and it was this was the three days
where they shut everything
and they hadn't announced the third
Escape so this was even the most scary
time for business owners they'd closed
you and they hadn't put anything in
place to support you and my dad was just
like you're gonna be okay
I know you I know what you're capable of
I believe in you I know how hard it
feels I know how tough it is I'm stood
in this stupid bridge covered in like
raid I was absolutely shooting it down
and I was just emotionally done and I
needed my dad of all people to pick me
back up and send me back out a fight and
after that call I kind of went home and
I did more strategizing and then then
that's a photo scheme and for the first
time in three nights I could sleep and I
could breathe again knowing that my
staff were going to be all right I I
didn't earn any money that year but they
they were okay they got paid and they
were really scared as everyone was you
don't know what's going on you don't
know what's coming and
I took care of them and I looked after
them and that was the number one thing
we took the decision that they were more
important than anything else so we went
through that so by the end of the year
too then was you still only in education
we still only in education this is at
the point where we realized we didn't
want to be in an industry that could be
closed down yeah and we realized that
our in our risk strategy you've got to
go abroad and you've got to go wider but
we don't want to do it really nearly
just to but okay uh kind of oh we're
scared we don't want to go out of
business within one area so we decided
to start spreading our risk and I don't
know if you can hear this yet but we've
got a People First strategy that means
if someone comes in with all of this
passion all of this hard work all of
this resilience we have to find a home
for them and the first person that was
was a lovely lad called Johnny and he
wanted to do finance and he'd be made
redundant through the pandemic and he
was really struggling and we said cool
we'll try finance and so we set up a
formula Associates and finance actually
in that short period got up and running
quite quickly
um Johnny then decided they want to do
something else as the pandemic lifted
but we kept the brand and we've kept
that moving since then but that was our
first foray into
securing our risk investment the second
one was the best one it was like I
didn't tell my finance manager for three
weeks I knew she'd kill me but a young
lad he was 21. he just tried a new
sector of recruitment he'd work tried to
work in space and it hadn't worked out
and the person that runs it was a friend
of mine he said I've got this kid and
you need to have him he was a
construction recruiter had been in it
for years and so this like quite shy 21
year old lad who's just been made
obviously let go or sacked whatever from
his job was like in front of me going I
need a job and I was like okay I don't
do construction at the moment but I love
construction I love the industry so cool
we'll go let's get on and I was like
right you've got a job and I've got to
explain this to my finance team and we
created a brand out of nothing in two
months time of what year was that this
was in 2020 so just after the as the
pandemic had eased but not over it's not
over
um and
we built this brand now nothing I didn't
even tell my finance manager there was a
new brand for three weeks because I knew
she'd Slaughter me because we were just
coming out the back end we needed to get
a clear Financial picture but I couldn't
let this young lad and his passion go to
waste that brand has since grown to
eight people is working with some tier
one contractors and it's got some
amazing hearts in it and it wouldn't
have happened if that Plucky young kid
hadn't walked in my room and gone right
I'm having it let's go he was so nervous
honestly he'll see this and he'll be
like he's talking about me so I'm not
gonna name him but he smashed it out of
the park and I couldn't have done it
without him and he was the people for he
was the start of the people focus
strategy find the best people you can
and give them the best opportunity you
can and guide them to the finish and
although the project that we started
with him isn't over
you could call it a success at this
point
so each different Brandon has that's
been the strategy absolutely you find a
brilliant personality with with all of
the things that you look for and you
give them the opportunity to to let it
flourish you don't do it on a kind of
tying them up basis you give them a
salary you take the risk out of it you
take some of the stress out of it and
then you invest in them to create that
business we're doing at the minute I've
got I've got an engineering brand off
the ground in the last three months and
the guy that runs it yeah 26 six years
experience super mistreated in his
career but so much knowledge cares so
much about what he does I've seen him
absolutely smash it out of the park and
that brand will have foreheads by the
end of this month and all because that
one bloke is just full of energy and is
willing to drive it to the finish and
you can feel that when you speak to him
hey everyone a real quick one from me
this podcast would not be possible
without our amazing podcast Partners Vin
cherry and saucebreaker because you
listen to this podcast you're able to
get your hands on exclusive savings on
both of these award-winning products if
you're a growing recruitment business
you have to check out vincere who are an
all-in-one operating system for your
growing recruitment business with Source
breaker if you want to make sure that
all of your recruiters have the best
tools on the market to stand out and
beat their competition then you have to
check out Source breaker use the link in
the show notes in the comments below and
you'll be able to get yourself exclusive
savings on these amazing products
so like I'm sure people be curious so I
would love to just hear your take on
this because you've done this a few
times now like if I walk in your office
and you feel the things that you feel
and you're describing and I identify an
industry that you're not currently in
what's like the blueprint what's like
the game plan to do you know what I mean
like what I tell my finance manager
but like yeah because it's competitive
how am I going to stand out how I'm
going to do things differently what's
the typical I don't know because you've
done this a few times now and there are
going to be nuances of different markets
but what what have become like the
fundamentals that you have to really
focus on in the first six to 12 months
I'll do the most recent one that we
really thought out um because the guy
that wanted it was really strategic in
his thinking he's not the sort of person
that's like Fly by Night gun shooter
very much a thinker really wants to know
what we're doing so he came in and sat
in my business for two weeks and did
nothing he just sat and watched which
Brown worked who did what how they were
the style of Recruitment and and got to
understand himself a bit better and how
he wanted to work and then we made the
decision we're going here and we're
getting into this business so then you
trigger a whole host of things so my CDO
Louise Billington brilliant people
manager so she would help shape the feel
of the brand Elliot then goes and gets
the market research from our head of
operations and we understand what a
market looks like in its entirety so if
we're going to take a small slice we
want to make sure that small slice is
big enough right and if it's a small
Market really Niche and it's going to
take seven years to build we go into
that with our eyes open turns out this
Market was going to be a pretty big one
and it had a lot of nuances and a lot of
kind of like
uh challenges in terms of terms of
conditions and legalities that we had to
figure out and so it probably took
another three weeks to plan and to
really sit and go through and make sure
that the person was comfortable because
if he wasn't comfortable and he wasn't
playing the game the way he wanted to he
wouldn't buy into it and wouldn't
achieve so we always make sure that
people sat in the sea that drive it are
comfortable with all the decisions made
and then he was comfortable green button
go and from there you're generating
demand you're finding applicants you're
getting them out and the blueprint is
the same for everyone else you get
really good candidates and you get them
in with good clients and you make money
that's the end goal right we all want to
get good people and good jobs no one
wants to place a crack candidate and
have a complaint or no one wants to
place a good person into a bad business
so once you identify the best clients
you start working with the ones that you
want to work with and I've seen this
this lad who had one year's experience
and it was I must admit one is
experience makes you think has he got
what it takes he absolutely has what it
takes he's got all of the skills that he
needs and with the right coaching and
the right support from my team and who
we are he will do incredibly well I I
will see him be successful whether it's
one of the last things I do or it's one
of the last things I think about every
night but he will because of his
attitude be very successful and the
blueprint always works so obviously I
completely understand that one of the
biggest lessons that sounded like that
you took from covert them was like the
importance of yeah diversification and
not having all your eggs in one basket
yep but like I can't help but think now
like how a naturally you got your sort
of um best friend as an operator and
then you've got obviously these key
people in the business now
but like I speak to so many recruitment
leaders who find themselves like just so
time poor stretched and they're doing
one market but niches within the market
so like how how does guy because I can I
can imagine like one yeah nine till 12
you've been said I've got these biggest
challenges in construction at the moment
12 to one you've got your engineering
guy a guy I'm struggling with this what
would you think but how how do you yeah
I don't know how does that work how do
you how have you been able to show up
there's one thing that's like a
superpower that I'm stuck with and I
can't really get away from and it's I'm
sorry to the guys that don't have it but
I've got ADHD so I spin plates that's
all I do I I can't sit still now you can
see me starting to move right it'll take
half an hour and I'll start twitching
and so if I'm not doing something that's
the worst version of me don't ever let
me get bored right because when I'm
bored stuff breaks so you have to keep
me entertained when I interview for
these people they interview me so you
come into it knowing what I've got on my
plate you know what I've got so you're
banking that that hour I can give you is
enough right or your banking that the
hour I give you or the hour that
everyone else has got or the three hours
that someone else has got spare is
enough
and you make that decision in the
process so if an hour of my time and my
wisdom is enough in recruitment to take
you on you you take the trade off and
certain brands take certain focuses
right you go like a yo-yo sometimes
you're in certain places and you've got
to catch up and you run around and
sometimes there's pressure's in in more
than more than one area at once and
that's when it gets really tough and
that's when you kind of you catch me
over the next last four weeks and it's
been difficult but that's when you dig
deep and that's why hard work and
passion becomes the two most important
things and resilience right at my level
right I have to be all the same things
as a trainee recruiter I have to sit in
their shoes I have to work the hours
they work I have to pick up the phone
when I don't want to I have to push my
passion Beyond where I thought I was
capable and we've always got that and as
long as you go back to your Basics like
a training recruiter you will be okay
and I take I take from that so yeah I'm
busy but the trade-off is that I get to
impact so many different people and
their progression gets to to be my
source of progression and I love to see
I'd love to see it so that's the bit
that excites me I get a little kick out
of it yeah I can tell I had that written
down because doing my research and I
think I heard you say on another podcast
like just Loosely about having ADHD but
I wasn't I wasn't actually sure if like
you've had a diagnosis yeah yeah before
we diagnosed they gave me some tablets
and they may be Bonkers never again
because uh I just want to ask you
um something about this like you do you
saw because my question was how do you
talk about this before but like how is
that sort of how have you how has you
having that diagnosis like manifested in
your professional life like it seems
like you just shared a bit there where
you're like I always have to be doing
something blah blah but just for those
people listening that may also have that
diagnosis like is there anything else
worth sharing that you've been on that
Journey that you found has enabled you
to get the best out of guy because some
of the best sales people I've worked
with
um have had ADHD yeah yeah and like I'll
be I'll be honest like one of my best
friends as well he got diagnosed with
ADHD was quite younger and like I don't
know
um they're some of my favorite people if
I'm honest I just love I'm tell your
energy is like I love that yeah like
yeah I don't know I guess everyone's on
their own Journey but is there anything
else to share on that you feel like has
helped guy get the best out or guy in
the work environment out of interest I'm
not broken I'm just different
um you could have a diagnosis I got mine
at 28 but I was really I always knew I
was a slightly different what made you
get that then or like I just thought
tell me God tell me tell me what I
already know right validate me I need to
be validated because it's loads of money
it's like 1500 quid to have it but
validate me right tell me there's
something different about me and then I
can understand it and I thought it would
help me understand it
no no so I got diagnosed and I had
nothing changed next day I carried on
exactly the same
I kind of say it more often now because
there are points when I get out of a
meeting I just I need to run around the
room right I need to get busy and
I can't think before I speak I will get
myself in trouble because I just exude
passion and energy and I just throw
myself into things and and I need to
explain that sometimes you say listen
I've got ADHD I actually occasionally
can't help it I can always always think
before I speak I can practice these
things but when I get out of this room
I'm gonna need to run around I'm gonna
need to like Sprint right I'm gonna have
to do some stuff to burn off this
additional energy and it comes out in
moving shaking and such a weird thing
but what a superpower for a salesperson
or a recruiter I could not handle the
volume or the pressure all the plates I
have to spit in which is the best
recruitment analogy to describe I'm
doing this all day without ADHD so I I
absolutely credit
75 of My Success random number but a lot
of My Success to being capable of
handling what people without ADHD or
people without that level
can do but we we've probably all got
something a bit different about us and
it's how we harness the harness these
superpowers and turn them into stuff for
us and yeah I don't like some of the
negatives like the overthinking the
worrying the not being able to sleep at
some nights and like all the bad bits of
ADHD and the fidgeting and all that I I
dislike that stuff but if I wouldn't
trade losing all the skills and the
superpowers I generate from it to get
rid of some of the bad stuff so I just
have to apologize more often man I
appreciate you sharing that so I guess
what I'd love to just hear your take on
then because like what what I'm sort of
continuing to learn here and gather is
like
where your recruitment business and and
the group was like after covert and then
covert is so different where it is now
because you found these amazing people
yeah you've ended up being a bit of a
blueprint and you've yeah ended up
building a bit of a methodology and yeah
like amazing opportunity to invest in
people the right people to take them
into markets so like what what have been
some of your most recent challenges or
like some of the biggest challenges that
maybe you least expected that have come
with having different brands operating
with way more people
great question
um training will always and has always
been the toughest part of the
recruitment industry the hiring big
Builders and getting them to build is is
kind of rudimentary it doesn't
necessarily work
um long term you want people that you've
crafted and shaped and talentia doesn't
have a unique Vision we're just
recruiters but we have a unique way of
doing things that's unique to us as far
as we're concerned
um so how we train people is the same
across every brand so my recruiters can
Hot Spot between Brands if they had to
right they lose the market knowledge but
they maintain the systems they maintain
the controls they maintain the candidate
care the client care the sales process
nothing changes so every brand is
different every brand has its unique
feel but the recruiters are trained the
same way and I think the biggest
challenge I've faced is training
recruiters I couldn't do it without
Elliot and I couldn't do it without
Louise and I couldn't do it without the
managers willing to put time into these
fresh grads these first job as the
second job as these these people that
are getting stuck into the recruitment
industry for the first time you need all
of the tools all of the resources and
all of the people to handle a model like
that we take 10 trainees at once and our
retention rate is staggering that's how
we've managed to grow so quickly is
having cohorts of people that bind
together work together across different
brands share all that knowledge in the
training and then they're coached and
guided by some of the industries best
and that's how we get them out and I
think without a without a plan for that
I don't know how any recruitment company
would scale and that that is the single
biggest success factor in my recruitment
company is brilliant training
supported by brilliant trainers what
about
um like has it been a challenge because
I've spoken to you a few times and
you've been in Manchester one time using
Nuki another time yeah like you have
different locations right yep how about
how how difficult is it been to like
have a culture the same culture
show up in Manchester like in these
different places line have like a Clear
Vision that everyone's bought into but
you're in different places I know you're
not in a different country but different
places have been a challenge yeah really
at the Forefront of things
um at the moment I would say so it's
really easy where I'm present because
the culture is what I embody and they
are my characteristics so it's really
easy where people I've worked with for
years are there it's when we have new
people in new places
um and how we get them to work the way
we work strong on boarding when you
bring these people through they have to
know why you do it they have to know why
they want to be in Recruitment and they
have to really hone in on what they want
for their progression and then having an
even progression strategy across all of
those businesses
matching your lunch times matching your
start times finish times you can't see
your colleagues another office going
home early or working later than you
without getting a bit upset about it so
really standardizing your process across
your locations and then FaceTime get
your big Builders moving around get you
get your noisy people that are going to
share knowledge get your trainers moving
around the businesses you need in
multiple locations more non-billing
staff than if you didn't right if you
tap into various tannables across
various places you will need more
non-billies to supervise those
operations and that's what we've noticed
is that we've got to send our people
that don't sit on a desk to more places
and really progress that
part of a culture is training and on
progression and so when we take that out
that's what we need to put into all
these other places so whenever we change
something we change it for everyone we
really make sure everyone feels like
part of the same thing it's still the
biggest challenge and
I don't know if I've got the answer for
you I I would really like someone to to
give me the answer if they know it but
we do as much right as we possibly can
and where we fail or we learn that
there's a mistake we listen and we
improve it but have you ever worked with
like a Ned or
Mentor or like because I know I speak to
a lot of recruitment leaders and that's
something that they really want and on
the odd occasion I'll refer people but
have you ever has that been something
you'd want to look for
depends on what your problem is there
are people out there that are suited to
certain problems and if your Ned isn't
asking you what your problem is before
they're trying to get you to set up a
subscription fee or kind of work with
them ongoing if they don't know what
your problem is don't listen to them if
they qualify you as a customer and they
understand you
brilliant and I've had a few I wouldn't
call them Neds they haven't come on in
long-term advisory but I've had a few
days where I've had people in that know
better than me and I've learned from
them and then adapted the process
um I think that's something we're going
through at the minute is a employee
proposition from a friend of mine John
Blackburn and that excites me more than
anything else because his sole benefits
for the employees I don't really mind
about any of it I think people are quite
happy but he's going to come in and
reshape our employee proposition and
that excites me more than a Ned telling
me how to run my finances or how to get
my client strategy enhanced because
leave that to them they will do it for
you
if you're given the right guidance but
yeah no so I think Ned's have a purpose
I think for a good Ned they really need
to understand your business
um so when you go to the market and ask
people make sure they ask you some good
questions first
so you've mentioned around you've backed
people and supported them yeah but I
think when when you're prepared for this
you mentioned like again feel free to
correct me if I'm wrong here but you
said around obviously you've also like
purchased free Brands yep is that right
yeah so mergers and Acquisitions are
kind of interesting
um because you take on board people's
clients that like to work with a certain
way second board employees that like to
work with a certain way how did this
come about Varsity always good people
okay yeah you find good people that are
maybe struggling with the market
struggling with their conditions
struggling with their training
struggling with being on their own maybe
um not enjoying where they've been and
where they've got to and then you you
talk to them and you find out what they
want to get and you decide if you two
matching up is a good partnership and if
you think you can develop their career
and you think you can take them Beyond
where they've taken themselves so far
you you say yes and you say cool what
you fix a fear you sort out an emerging
process and then you go from there and I
can say that not all of them have been
successful but that all works in
progress so if you're willing to
someone's willing to give you the faith
to take their business and take it
further you have to repay that and the
person I'm talking about will know what
I'm talking about but trust me I'm going
to help him and we are going to take
that business to a place that's never
been before and we will take it on but
it's not going to be without Challenge
and strife and how we shape these things
is hugely important so if you are going
to do a merger or an acquisition
understand their why and make sure it
matches your why and make sure where you
both want to get or the organizations
want to get together is clearly mapped
out because without that they might as
well carry on on their own they'll carry
on doing whatever they were doing make
sure you know exactly why you're doing
it but like that isn't something that
just like you don't just end up in
someone's LinkedIn DMS and start talking
about that like did you intentionally
look for these opportunities did you
actually just end up in someone's death
really yeah man so um you don't have to
tell me like particularly how it
happened but I didn't like because I
feel like you're too happy you've been
quite intentional about it you tap
people up right
how you doing you're right how is
everything
everything going well yeah it's all good
really I'm just oh maybe this oh mate I
can help you with that no problem and
then as you begin to maybe help them for
a charge or help them for a charge or
whatever as you begin to impart
knowledge though they might think
actually I like that I'll come and come
and have a chat come and have a coffee
come and sit in with us see what you
like and um they've all gone like that
it's all been you good yeah I'm all
right but I got these pain points oh
cool well I can fix all that you just
got to give me a bit more of your time
and then you fix it and then they maybe
see what you're offering and you go
listen what about this how does this
sound to you can we talk about this one
of them was because someone got drunk
and said you should do this and and then
it came to fruition you two will also
know I'm talking about you but I love
that as well
um and that was hilarious like one
really valued member of my team text
someone else while he was pissed saying
you guys need to do a merger and he went
cool sounds like a great idea and no one
expected it and then thus at the whole
we've got another brand and we're like
great okay how did that happen but the
vision's aligned then and I was on the
phone is one of the really
one of the really exciting prospects the
guy's gone from a brand of two to now
having a team of nine and he's on track
to a team of
probably 20 by the end of next year and
he's absolutely loving it I hope he said
he was um but yeah totally off the back
of the DM so you just mentioned how when
it comes to merges the importance of you
understanding now why them understanding
your way but I just wanted to ask before
we moved on like
because you've done a couple of these
now what what would you say it might be
the the answer but like what would you
say are the sort of non-negotiable is
when it comes to a merger being the
right thing or a merger working cultural
fit Financial due diligence and knowing
where you're going to take it have an
exit point in mind but don't be set on
Stone because exit points will change
you will be a bit fluid because
conditions adapt and you've got to be
tougher than that but know the numbers
underneath that business and know the
metrics um one of them I looked at their
best year and I said that's our best
case scenario and then I took their
worst year and said that's where we're
at so if I can get them from their worst
year and make them profitable and make
them grow that's the number I take so
the worst year was what I took and I
went with that and I was expecting that
to be the worst year they tripled it but
we went for the worst year and then
cultural fit that person's got to get
along with your business and the people
you have in it and if they don't like
your senior team don't like your exacts
don't like your support staff
it's a no-go yeah you have to get along
with the people that I brought in
because they're here for the journey and
it's always been whenever someone's had
a disagreement with any of my senior
team they've never lasted that long I
back my people 100 and I support them
100 and when their guts are triggering
it's not right then that's not right for
me you need friends in business you need
people that are around you that protect
you from yourself sometimes and talenti
has definitely developed a really good
nose for when people will fit and won't
fit
um and that might make it sound a bit
like a cold but to some degree your
culture needs to be so important to you
that when people come in they do need to
fit and people will adjust a bit there's
always Flex in things you can always
bring someone on this a little bit
outside
but if your gut's telling you
something's wrong
yeah that's right it almost always is
and you should trust it
so as we come to the end here I wanted
to ask because again I was doing my
research and stuff I was looking at you
I always like to look at people's
LinkedIn posts and stuff like that no no
yeah you do
um share a lot of things which I really
like but I guess I saw I wanted to you
we've spoken a lot about the business of
Journey been on but obviously for you as
a person I think the the Post-it Line's
referred to as like you shared a picture
of you like 20 stone and then like
losing weight
why are you doing that to me because no
one needs to know because I wanted to
like because I think
I I've been on my own sort of Journey
but like you can find yourself very easy
to put everything into work and then the
other stuff
I don't know you just don't do it you
know what I mean or like it's like yeah
how how have you got better yeah but
you've you've turned it around so like
how have you got how do you think you've
got better or like had has it been a
challenge for you to get a bit more of
that like putting guys a human being
first and not just obviously the
business and everything else like it's
funny you say that I have to say I'm a
human more recently I think people think
because you get a lofty title and you're
the CEO that you stop being a human and
maybe you do maybe maybe I'm getting it
wrong and that I'm not allowed to be
myself anymore but I decided
about a year ago that I needed my life
back and as much as you can trade
everything for money and for guts and
glory and taking a business and a vision
and a dream if I'm not healthy enough to
be the the head of the table and not not
healthy enough to take that place then
it's not all going to be for nothing and
so I was just sad with how I looked how
I felt where I was at I was given my
soul to a business that was giving it
back to me and the people in it gave it
back to me but I wasn't giving any love
to myself
and so I had to had to get consistency
in my my routine in my food in my gym
and buy some time back uh what people
wouldn't know is at the same time as
going and losing all that weight I also
worked abroad every month for a week
really to take a bit of life back so I
spent a week in Barcelona I spent a week
in Italy France I was all over the all
over the globe
um buying my time back and looking
outside into the business working just
as hard and nothing slept if anything I
worked harder Max will remember the week
I was in Barcelona just grafting walking
20K every day and just being like what
has happened why are we stuck it 20 20
steps and it was harder work than if I
was sat in my office in Bristol and I
was like I don't really know what we're
doing and I I decided that things that I
do that I can enjoy and the business
would be a vehicle for that is okay it
doesn't have to be work 14 15 hours a
day doesn't have to be takeaway every
night it doesn't have to be like lunch
at your desk you could buy a time back
with investment and I invested in myself
and I'm now a happier person I am a
human
um and I think people do well to
remember we're all just people be kind
to yourselves to your colleagues to
everyone where you can I think I think
some people are annoyed yeah but why did
you bring that up that's not fair oh
yeah I was pretty yeah it's called the
recruitment Stones we've all got it
right anyone watching this will know
what happens when you say as you get
there in the stone because you did
something about it that's why I wanted
to highlight it a lot a lot of people
don't recruitment Stones man they're
coming for everyone yeah yeah of course
but so I guess what like someone that
might be feeling like that then what
would your advice be to them because you
clearly arrived at the moment were like
enough's enough like someone's listening
I think you know what yeah I haven't put
myself first or I'm putting myself last
all the time don't wait don't wait for
that moment because I really like what
you just said there because that's sort
of my mentality I'm not always perfect
but like you said how can I be that you
said that the head of the table but not
healthy enough to be there and stuff
like what is what's the point yes
um
don't let it get there right if people
are telling you you don't look well or
people are telling you that you need to
take some time and you need to take care
it's because people give a [ __ ] they
care they want you to to be the best
person yourself listen to them I think
Louise was telling me to go to to eat
properly for like
I don't know three years fine and and in
the end it's like right cool now I'm
eating properly now I'm going to the gym
and I'm looking after myself and I was
as consistent with my gym work and my
food as I am with my recruitment it's a
process repeated over and over again and
always man you go back to being a
trainee I go back to my Basics my My
Back to Basics is is what I do with my
trainees whenever they're struggling
back to basis do I taught you do I do
what do you do at the very beginning and
I I was I was slander once as a young
lad and I knew that if I ate right and I
stuck to my simple bits I could get back
there I got a big frame now and trying
to get back to maybe me as like a 14
Stone kid isn't going to be as
successful but going back to my Basics
and drumming myself to be that everyday
inconsistent
just yielded results and I I feel so
much better yeah yeah so what what as we
come to the end here then what what's
next for
for the group what what's what's on
there what's on the The Horizon what's
going on investing in the people we've
got and
using tools like recruitment mentors
using tools like
um new technologies that gets emerged um
I'm really enjoying some of the new
stuff that's coming through the market
and testing and trialing things we're on
a journey to 300 people uh and it's
going to take a hell of a lot of effort
300 people because they have a lot of
effort to get there and it's going to
need a lot of time love and attention
and like 300. magic number
three is a magic number
um
it might sound silly to someone that
maybe hasn't got a large number of Staff
but the more stuff you have the less
risk you have so we with that would be
250 sales staff and 50 support staff and
with 250 sales staff I don't have to
make 10 or 20 grand per person I can run
that at a lesser profit margin and
invest more into those people and get
more return from them and still make 250
Grand a month which is enough of a
buffer maybe some people will say that
you want a bigger buffer right and as
your appetite for risk grows or shrinks
you'll change that buffer and you'll
turn the business to to achieve what you
want from life and at 250 Consultants
there is enough for me and my top level
directors and my social directors and My
Business Leaders to take from it more
time and buy back more time collectively
so our plan is as a team to buy back our
lives over the course of the next six
years to to live a better life and make
sure that we stay true to the core which
is to make sure that those good people
that we employ also have great lives 36
of my staff own their own homes wow
massive important start for me because
that means that people are progressing
in their lives outside of work and in
work and that embodies what my guys are
trying to do my top team are all trying
to do the same thing but they're trying
to buy their lives back after giving it
all to Recruitment and I think at 250 my
top team can all buy their lives back a
bit more than before as people more
people come through
Kyla I absolutely love your energy love
your passion I think it's amazing I
can't turn it off
but like generally I think if you like
definitely like where you was going into
covid or when you maybe first thought
about your business and what it is now
and the things you're dealing with on a
weekly basis the leader that you have to
show up and be like I think I think it's
amazing like you've also had to continue
to reinvent yourself you've been on your
own personal Journey business journey
and it's I'm sure you just feel like
you're just getting started I don't even
get it right man I've made mistakes and
I've probably upset some people and I
will I probably will do again but from
the depths of my heart I'm just a human
and I will do better so hold me to
account I think something that's really
powerful you have to listen to what
people say about you and you have to
take it on board even if you don't like
it and I won't always like what people
say about me and that's cool people will
watch this and maybe not like it but
listen to them and and take what
learning lessons you can from the
negatives and the positives and yeah
that's that's what's next I'm going to
know more and do better and be better so
I'm coming for you to do better I love
it thank you very much thank you so much
for listening to the episode I hope you
enjoyed it and got value from the
conversation if you did enjoy it please
don't forget to like share and subscribe
and we'll see you in the next episode